after the class were you like okay La
for me no
um I well that's not true I I thought
well that got canceled but I should
probably stick around here for I now
have a bed in La
um see what happens but then the rider
strike happened oh boy and uh all work
kind of dried up yeah so I was going
back and forth to New York and I was
doing I was doing a workshop of um
actually a musical version of the movie
Elf as the as the Will Ferrell part and
so you know what I uh were you the the
oh no that I'm sorry I'm thinking of
something else I'm thinking of the Santa
Land diary
which I also did when I was young oh did
you yeah yeah David Sedaris piece yeah
yeah
um but I was workshopping this musical
and so I was like well that this I'll
probably end up back in New York doing
that and then um when the strike ended I
um I got a script of a new show called
um Do Not Disturb about it was kind of
an Upstairs Downstairs
uh uh succumb about a hotel and I was I
was in the down stairs
you know they put the ugly people down
oh I know but it's true
um and uh that show got canceled um
after I think three or four episodes uh
it had terrible ratings and um I was
like this isn't Gonna Last yeah and uh
the next season uh was Modern Family so
I went from the show that was canceled
first of the of the entire season to the
show that won the Emmy so yeah I went
right from the bottom to the top yeah
yeah which is crazy what was I mean how
soon after the uh
the debut the premiere of Modern Family
did you feel your life because I imagine
your life changed dramatically you know
yeah
um
I mean we we got all this Emmy love on
our after our first season and that felt
really crazy I um we was never expecting
that for myself I kind of saw it maybe
happening for Eric and and Ty
um but you know they they really
showered all of us with a lot of
um a lot of love and I was like oh this
is this is resonating in a way that I
don't even think I understand wow
um and uh you know but the thing about
the thing about this business is you're
you're always like looking for
um the pink slip you're you're you know
you just it's it's it's constantly a
career of um being fired or being let go
or or things just disappearing and so I
I think you know especially in the
theater I mean like you never have a job
for too long yeah so I just I just
didn't have it it wasn't part of my
psyche that this was going to be
something that would be
um a consistent job and I was I just I
had a I think it was even like season
four or five I was like okay I think
we're I think we're okay now
um but yeah it ended up being a a jaw
that lasted for 11 years which is just
unheard of yeah you know in this
business was it long enough too long the
perfect it might have been a little too
long but I'm happy we did that you know
I think we there was an opportunity to
end after season 10.
um and I'm just really happy that we got
to do one last season knowing that it
was gonna be our last season because it
gave us that year to sort of say a
really long slow goodbye right right
um and just enjoy it and really take it
all in yeah
um so I'm I I'm grateful for the 11th
year but I think probably we were all
exhausted yeah um I don't think we did
anything super revolutionary in that
last year
um but I'm glad that you know fans uh
are I think we're happy that we gave
them one more year and yeah
um it certainly was you know I made some
more money which is great yeah yeah I
imagine yeah I think the writers were
kind of like oh yeah yeah okay all right
what have we got you know it's a lot of
episodes that they have to come up with
yeah sure yeah um is there something in
your mind
to do something with your career that
will Top Modern Family like is that is
that it's something a thought that
you've actually sort of formulated
um I don't I don't know if anything will
Top it necessarily but I mean a nice
companion piece yeah yeah
um you know I I I just did a play on
Broadway and I won a Tony Award for it
so it's like you know that that was a
you know coming from if we're like gonna
fast forward congratulations thank you
thank you everybody look you rewind back
to us beginning this conversation we're
like I was just a kid who went to
theater yeah and The Ensemble of Les
Miserables like then I won a Tony Award
so it's like for me that was
um that was a moment that when it was
happening I was like okay this is this
is a big deal yeah this and and that
that whole experience of that play of
take me out um was a career highlight
for me I just you know I mean I got to
do so much with modern family but you
know I didn't get to use my full toolbox
and there's this character that I got to
play in this play was um you know it was
multi-layered in ways that just you
can't do on a sitcom yeah the audiences
aren't interested in super multi-layered
characters and sitcoms they kind of want
prototype right um and uh so that was it
was just it felt really good after 11
years of doing something you know where
your your episodes are crammed into 22
minutes to do this like out two and two
and a half hour play where you get to
really explore a character it was really
liberating
um and I I it opened up my desire to do
things that um surprise people
um uh I I would love to do something
more dramatic um I love you know when I
when Modern Family started uh there was
no streaming platforms yeah it was just
all network television so I I love that
this I mean I felt like it came out of a
bunker when Modern Family I was like
where are we what's going on what is
this what is this um you know industry
now and uh I I love that there's there's
so much great content out there and um
that you know you don't necessarily have
to be tied down to this contract that
will last you another 11 years yeah
if you had to choose
um stage
TV or movies
well
um I mean I'm in a lucky position
because I've I've made some money doing
TV because it again you don't make a
working a living wage for very long and
doing doing theater
um but I do love I mean there's for me
it's always will be theater first yeah
is if you're asking me like what what
fills my soul yeah yeah and what fills
my bank account is something different
what do you think I mean what is I mean
there's obvious differences but I mean
what what is it about the theater that
speaks to you more so than than filmed
it's you know Eric Stone Street would
always make fun of me on Modern Family
because I would love to rehearse and
like you know he's like let's just do it
yeah yeah just tell us where the gun was
to do it yeah I love that improv guy
he's an improv guy he's great at that
yeah
um and with theater you know you get
this like long rehearsal process and you
really get to figure these people out
and
um really study the material and you
have these long discussions with the
other actors about it and it's just it
feels just so rich and then you know
with with television and film you know
you you do that you do something you do
a day it's work and then they an editor
takes it and and kind of Frankensteins
it together into this performance that
ends up being on television or on film
and you know in theater you are the
editor you yeah what what you you it's
one long take yeah and you you're just
with the audience for that for that long
take and no other audience will ever see
that long take again yeah that that
performance it's it's that's be unique
to that day and there's just something
so special and electric about that to be
in a room with all these strangers
watching something that will never
happen the same way again yeah
um you know we do the same play the
words are mostly the same unless someone
you know changes them or
Jesse Williams would always go up in his
lines he would just forget what he was
saying and make up I was like that
is not what the playwright wrote but
we're still on the track so good good
for you yeah um but you know it is it's
it's that performance just takes place
in that moment I think that's so special